definitely i think part of it as well
like from obviously the women's
perspective
once like they feel like someone's
wronged them
anything they can do to just to get you
back
they're doing it if they have to lie is
that true
that's actually you're laughing you're
laughing it's just like there's there
are some girls like that's what it is
how is it that you two are just going to
completely differ
like i think
part of being different is like
every girl's a little crazy like i'm not
above like it's just like if you know
you're crazy you're not gonna do crazy
[ __ ] you know what i mean
because like like if i'm getting
emotional i'll just be like oh i'm just
like i'm a girl i'm being emotional like
just give it a day or two
but like a lot of girls they live in
this like delusion
like
like
and they think like they think
no they think they think just because
they're angry or they're mad or they're
more emotional than men they can just do
whatever they want
or or
or they'll blame it on their childhood
which i understand maybe that's why but
like you i'm sorry if you're over the
age of like 21 18
get over it so you feel like everyone
always look one thing goes wrong
everyone always look for that thing
because they don't want to believe that
i'm this horrible so they gotta look for
something to say hey do you think that's
what it is no girls can men can't like
if a dude if a girl hits a dude she'll
say oh like i witnessed abuse
that's why and that's okay that makes it
okay but but the men if they hit a girl
prison like they're like they don't
what's your excuse
no people don't they might say that but
they're not going to get a mic like
they're not going to be given the
platform and i think it's a bit
difficult if a half of her face is
hanging off the side
for anyone to see that hey he was
because i think that's what might be off
the rip like a guy if you punch a woman
her face is going to be like this and i
feel like that's a distraction in itself
from people trying to understand your
perspective i'm like oh my god
look at this woman watch me
i can also punch as hard you know
your chest to like decorate yeah
of course but like there i don't know
there's a difference between a girl like
like
you shouldn't do it at all but there's a
difference between a girl like play
hitting you
[Laughter]
it just changes your whole mindset about
this whole thing the day a [ __ ] punches
you
all of this four persons comes out of
the window no i just
i'm pretty good at getting people to
like call like i have people that like
get amped on my show but i don't know
i've never been on this show what is
that on this show yeah i bet people get
like like i'm just like one's fine no no
just like they're more aggressive
like if someone gets mad like i just
still talk to them same level but
it might happen one day i hope
i hope not the more i talk maybe
the bigger this gets
yeah
that's crazy
it's crazy i like your perspective on
certain things it's very uh real
which is good a lot of
girls will call you pikmi
[Laughter]
oh you just say yeah i don't say this
stuff because i don't i believe what i
said yeah yeah
but if you're going to say oh you want
to get picked do i want to die alone
come on no no
you should use this clip
the main thing is
guys the main thing is as long as you're
true to yourself what you're saying
that's all that matters right no if you
come out as i pick me you'll pick me
well i grew up i i respect my dad a lot
my dad like i think i call him a little
too much like he wants me to like call
him last
daddy's going no but i have like nine
siblings and i grew up between two boys
so i just like okay i feel like you
can't the same men are trash if like you
respect the men around you
and a lot of a lot of times these girls
like didn't have men like either the dad
is like super weak so he like never
stood up for himself so she didn't
respect it yeah kind of like well like
will smith let's talk about it like like
like dude they're kids do the kids sound
like they respect well no no when when
they're like talking about how they wish
tupac was here
so so you have that dynamic and then you
have the other dynamic where the dad
just like wasn't there but then a lot of
times it goes back to they don't know
why he wasn't there because a lot of
times like men are pushed out of the
kid's life because like men don't really
have rights in court
so it's like they're there's just where
have you been all our lives
write a book or something it's real
that's real well it's just
you listen to men talk like a lot of it
these aren't absolutely i don't make
this stuff up myself like are you
serious
that's very good very well raising you
so even that women just
choose to ignore all of those facts that
you're obviously absorbing and
understanding well i think a lot of
girls haven't heard it okay so like i
grew up with a like because my my
personality is very much like
like like left okay and i'm very
conservative and so but like my like my
personality traits if i take a
personality test it puts me at like the
95th percentile left because i'm very
creative i'm open to like the
personality traits that tend to go with
like more liberal people like that's why
if you meet someone that lives in a van
like you assume they're more left yes
and if you meet someone that's like an
accountant you assume they're more right
it's because of the personality traits
that are associated with it but my dad
would just like break every like every
time i'd like want to go that way my dad
would just like break it down
and like you know i was a little bit
more left in college but my dad would
just like break down every single thing
that would make me want to go that way
okay and so i just think it's really
important for women to be surrounded by
men they respect because otherwise like
like then they have a tainted view of
man
that's very true and i also believe that
a lot of women
they feel the same way
you feel
within themselves they feel the same way
they have the same perspectives you have
but won't
come out and say it
it goes there's a culture that makes
many shits cool there's a many [ __ ]
culture cool
even uh yeah we know that
that man might be right but man
yeah
yeah
that guy hurts me in you know back in
uni
well i i think that's something i think
there's more reasonable women than like
people really especially in this sector
of youtube like bring out like believe
to be honest i have girls all the time
on my show most of them aren't ratchet
most of them aren't like hate man-hating
but it's just like the ones that are so
loud right and most women are more
agreeable they're not gonna say stuff
because like they're they're just more
agreeable and yeah and
my advice to just
men out there is that
live in a real world not social media
because again we can easily i've said
this before in our podcast as well like
we can easily just if you're stuck on
social media it's easy for you to think
everyone's opinion is that right where
we're missing the fact that majority of
people
the population probably don't are not
there so something like oh all women are
the only one gold they're they're gold
diggers the only one this or that that
that expectation but you can whatever
level you are in life
whatever situation you are you walk you
can find a woman that can compensate
that and take you to that next level
so i feel like and you have to
understand the media like
even for my show like to be honest i
wish i had more feministy liberal girls
that could come on it's a better show
like
it's something yeah
because i personally like the battle of
ideas does better it's good yeah yeah
yeah conversation
it's not fun it's not good enough yeah
and so if i can find like people that
are like i have girls that i'm friends
with that i'm like you're my villain
come on yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so it's like
it's you're gonna see it more like i'm
sure fresh and fit do the same thing or
all the mail
podcasts they have to yeah it's good
it's good media now you're not really
kicking people off
well they want that though yeah because
it's working how much money did they
make off of those videos
yes i'm not hating on it
like i'm trying to if you guys know any
feminists
i don't know i don't know i know one or
two yeah i would introduce them to you
no don't bring them don't tell them who
i am
i'll bring them no we'll talk though i'm
i'm really worried not not for right now
right now right now but i'm looking like
the next 10 20 years
i'm worried for the
upcoming generation like the women
okay because the way
the
society is right now if it keeps going
this way
they're literally creating a divide
between men and women they're putting
you in a position where i remember back
in the days growing up here i don't know
i was like in america like
if i see a girl across the road i'm on
this side and she's like she catch me i
can jog across the road hey darling
you're right what's your name where you
from did it i can do that you can't do
that i remember growing up you cannot do
that now y'all you're weird or you're a
creep you're this you're that
facts